[Music]
so 243 pounds
of contraband blank
were seized at the u.s
texas border i'm sorry the texas mexico
border 250 blank 243 pounds of black
marijuana
cocaine
contraband
country brand blank
what is considered
what's a contraband vaccine cards a
controlled item
vaccine cards i think it's just illegal
right you can't have it
fireworks contraband cavity fillings
nope nope um
guns
cream cheese
caviar more more clothes you're closed
you're so close
what is it untaxed salsa contact salsa
no prescription grade mouthwash
no that's good i've used that before
it's good
mexican steroids oh that's a good no um
do you normally give us a hand give us a
hint
baloney
there's [ __ ] really
contrabanded balloons
that's the hint oh the hand okay hot dog
meat pepperoni contraband two-headed
cows no
pigs
you're close
unreleased lunchables
like future
joe's really
cool not close to pigs it's hot dogs
piggy banks
it's bologna
oh you seriously regular below you came
the closest the hint i gave you guys a
hint you said the thing
i gave you a hand
baloney
so yeah
pork products have the potential to
introduce foreign animal diseases that
can have devastating effects to use
okay so when you're crossing the board
right so it's illegal bologna don't
bring produce jumping certain foods you
gotta fill out that car yeah a
customer's car
250 pounds that is that like a
commercial shipment worth of baloney
that's a lot it's a little boring all
right how do we smuggle it in
that's the question that's the 100 do it
right how do you do it right that's what
i wanted to get to what's the right way
going from mexico to texas there's only
a straight line remember it's bologna so
it's a little bit different than
something like say cocaine yeah easy
sell the bologna
okay you're crazy dudes what's this
baloney world i don't get it how does
that work all right this is what you do
what's the conversion rate what's the
goal this is what you do okay joe all
right you make sandwiches with all the
bologna it sounds delicious in a picnic
basket go across the border you still
have that problem though where they see
it's blown they know it's no but but but
now it's not commercial
now it's my lunch how much how much you
crossed the border you de-sandwiched the
bologna these sandwiches now you put it
into bologna packets but now you can
also separately sell the tomatoes the
tomatoes you could sell the lettuce
recess i saw the bread that was my
question
so this time bread is smart so if you're
smuggling one sandwich one time you
gotta go like 2 000 times back and forth
bread that had tomato juice on it
briefly for at least six hours what's
the where's the plane
no playing oh it's a new plan it's a
picnic plan come on get what the times
made big plan well i think anthony has a
different idea okay what's your idea
anthony yeah what's the idea
me
i told you my picnic plan all right you
think the customs people are going to
really believe that you're going to eat
that much
he's doing one sandwich at a time he's
just going 90 dollars 200 250 times here
we go all right
mexican elementary school yeah
field trip you you buy a [ __ ]
catering car 2000 kids all right you get
a catering company all right some
overhead for this plan you work you work
your ass off for a couple years yeah
yeah
you grow the value of the catering
company get some good yelp reviews for
your catering company okay okay you you
get you buy a few buses build the
business you get all the [ __ ] uh
mexican orphans yeah remember 250 pounds
of bologna 250. then you sell the
business for a plane
no and then you make bought out
you go public whole business for one
plane you make 2 500 sandwiches okay
okay put it in coolers
go over the border say we're doing a
field trip to san diego
right what happened to the texas the
kids the kids i'm going this way not yet
ethically sourced orphans ethically
sourced
i like that actually perfectly sourced
organic okay that's super cool we unload
them free range we try we get us we get
a assembly line
and then they de-assemble the sandwich
we repack the bologna and then there we
go you assemble the lines
what happens to the orphans at the end
we go back to mexico
they're working so they're no better off
there's gonna we're gonna have tacos
when we get home you know like it's only
a three hour job bologna tacos three
hours why did we buy this plane
it's just sitting there
what's the point oh wait we gotta that's
my vlog
let's say we get ten thousand bologna
now we're talking plane prices okay okay
because i'm gonna buy a plane for 250
pounds of bologna okay what's the resale
value
it's below maybe we'll get a motorcycle
okay how much is a plane real quick how
a plane it at least 250 000 if if you're
getting the cheapest one yeah well
between fifteen thousand and a hundred
thousand all right how much is 250
pounds of baloney
wholesale price how much does bologna
move well we're first selling they can
sell retail i don't know
anymore
no it's people were moving bologna dude
how we smoking how he's smuggling blood
oh he's smoking bologna dude why are
they why are they smuggling it though
it's worth like four g's all right four
g's this is what we do you buy
a bunch of buses and with orphans in
them for four g's
it's pretty cheap in mexico believe me
man you're gonna spend a hundred grand
to smuggle four g's okay i bought a
donut there
i bought a donut there for 10 cents oh
my goodness
if you scale it off that yeah it's a
savings
that's so smart though because what if
we buy them for 10 cents in mexico then
we sell donuts in america for [ __ ]
the dollars oh [ __ ]
you know we just 10x we're missing it
we're missing them
we just need a plane to bring it all out
that's stupid i just buy the plane yeah
the plane went by itself to buy
unlimited donuts in america that's
pretty good yeah
did you buy a plane in mexico to buy
donuts in america is that what you just
said 100
so agricultural specialists discovered
five rolls of undeclared mexican bologna
hidden under bags of chips as well as in
the trunk compartment under the seats of
a of a vehicle while it was crossing the
border oh so they intentionally like hit
it to smuggle it oh they knew it there
they didn't have any orphans smuggling
bologna under bags of chips sounds like
a really big picnic
it so far does i bet in their mind
they're like no one's gonna check 250
pounds is a lot too though so 55 pounds
of the baloney was discovered in the suv
and the driver and informed specialist
that he resells the baloney in the u.s
for almost double the price he paid in
mexico kind of like the donuts the
donuts yeah
uh the second scheme the second
discovery
uh donuts is a better one on january
21st when the u.s citizen and the luna
resident of colorado presented herself
for inspection via vehicle the driver
also gave negative declaration
uh and was referred for a secondary
inspection so she says that like no i
don't i don't have anything and then she
got referred for a secondary inspection
after saying that she doesn't have
anything because they and then they
found 19 bowls of pork bologna weighing
188 pounds under the real seat inside
duvet covered liners and luggage wow
how do they keep the bologna cool though
don't they need to kevin like ice cream
i know nothing but ice packs that's bad
man you can't do that to meat man but
that's what they do right they resell it
like
like more expensive in the united states
i wish i would go to tulum just to eat
[ __ ] donuts again so like the way
that they do donuts there's these guys
that run roll around with donut boxes
and then they're like it's it's got like
a donut box in front of a bicycle handle
or some [ __ ] and they [ __ ] they they
[ __ ] like weld it onto the front of
the bicycle so they go around they go
right and then when they open it it's
like oh it's so warm because it's fresh
and flies fly out and [ __ ]
and you're like oh what do i even choose
from you got cinnamon rolls you got
[ __ ] something that looks like a
croissant but it's a lie it's actually a
donut and then like he's like no no man
and then like you could bargain for it
and then i'm like i'll pay you 10 cents
are they good they're amazing
the flies are that's a big indicator
yeah flies level
yeah and in some dudes they're they're
they're more luxurious they have like a
uh they have like a plastic one so they
don't have to open it and you can choose
and you'll be like i want this one and
then they'll open it for you there's no
flies for that one sometimes there still
is but yeah a little bit but nine out of
ten flies don't lie yeah that's a good
donut yeah man they have some it's good
i don't know why i'm like why can't you
make donuts like that here winchell's
what's up man
what about crispy
no it's not the same it's like
it's like you know those cambodian donut
shops right like that they all have
those big fat ones and it's fluffy
imagine that
but it just is it's it just tastes like
more fresh or something i don't know
what it is like greasier okay yeah oh it
could be so the bologna unfortunately
was seized and destroyed by the border
patrol
i wonder what the memories of
construction how did they destroy
bologna during a picnic
they destroyed them in their bellies
that's what it means okay you know a
better thing is you buy pigs all right
you sound like the [ __ ]
plug why did we do it why do we do this
because it's it's it's the whole
wholesale okay and the thing is baloney
can't walk pigs can
are you sure
if you walk that way you're willing to
go on a record about that
you walk you buy the pigs you walk it
over the border you just walk in with
you yeah
that don't cost nothing you got to pay
[ __ ] gas money technically mean
you're not trafficking if they just
happen to be walking with you joe's the
idea is guy that you pay and he sits in
a bar and he's like
he's like baloney doesn't
walk but pigs do
you're like oh [ __ ] hold on thank you
and you leave you have an amazing idea
you need to pay me you didn't get it
he's like that's amazing he just breaks
his car he was getting going
so the pigs walk yeah all right you go
over the border um you're walking your
pigs what are they gonna say you got
your id you know they're gonna be like
hey hey no no no you can't bring your
pigs over here it's like what i walk my
dog
i walk my horse my pet yeah yeah that's
normal
you put the red vest on them it's my
emotional [ __ ] it's my emotional support
what are they gonna say to me and they
can't ask for papers yeah this is normal
i only have 200 of them
this is stressing my emotions out just
having to go through yeah the border
patrol be like oh i'm sorry you're
american you're so yeah i'm so sorry
you're an american wow you're one of us
and i'm like yeah don't worry about it
i won't sue all right literally i was
about to cry and i don't worry about it
i'm about to have a [ __ ] panic attack
right now you know
yeah they're like no no don't have a
panic attack don't you yeah and be like
literally i walk over with the pigs yeah
that's good go to my bologna connect
and i turned them into bologna and
hopefully you took the vest off
beforehand but if not then i guess the
vest got chucked in there too it'll be
emotional support baloney okay emotional
support baloney
you